¿Por qué Donald Trump tiene tanto interés
en castigar a la República Islámica de Irán?
Si habéis visto todos los vídeos que hemos
hechos en esta serie, pensaréis que su interés
es subir los precios del petróleo, o ayudar
a sus amigos de Arabia Saudita… o tal vez,
lo que quiere es demostrar su poder ante la
Unión Europea. Pero hoy os voy a dar otra
hipótesis ¿Y si lo que realmente quiere
Donald Trump es acabar con el autoritarismo
en Irán? No es ninguna teoría descabellada...
Irán está al borde del colapso económico.
Las protestas contra el gobierno son cada
vez más frecuentes. Y, a diferencia de otros
países de la zona, Irán SÍ tiene una oposición
secular, liberal y democrática. Es decir,
que no hace falta librar una guerra con bombas,
tanques y muertos para traer la democracia
a Irán. Bastaría con ahogar económicamente
el país para que acabar con los ayatolás.
Si este plan saliera bien, Donald Trump podría
ganar el premio Nobel de la paz. Obama se
la tendría que envainar y casi seguro que
volvería a ganar las elecciones. Pero ¿Y
si no sale tan bien? ¿De verdad el régimen
de los Ayatolás es tan débil como pensamos?
¿Puede ganar esta apuesta Donald Trump? En
este vídeo te lo vamos a explicar.
Irán es el enemigo favorito de los Estados
Unidos. Por supuesto, la Casa Blanca asegura
que las sanciones de Trump al país de los
ayatolás no buscan acabar con el regimen
pero… ¿Hasta qué punto es cierto?
El asesor nacional de seguridad de la Casa
Blanca, John Bolton, dice que Estados Unidos
no quiere derrocar al gobierno de Irán y
asegura que, lo que Washington quiere es que
las autoridades de Tehrán cambien de actitud
Lo cierto es que, desde hace décadas, Estados
Unidos ha intentado hacer todo lo posible
para acabar con el régimen de los Ayatolás.
Por ejemplo ¿Habéis oído hablar alguna
vez de Radio Free Europe? Durante la guerra
fría, el congreso de Estados Unidos creó
esta radio para lanzar mensajes anticomunistas
en el Bloque Soviético. Hoy en día, esa
radio sigue existiendo. Es más, tienen sus
oficinas aquí, en Praga. Más concretamente
en el mismo barrio donde vivo. Y en esta radio
tienen todo un departamento dedicado a Irán,
con programas y noticias en farsi. Es decir,
que en Washington sí que están interesados
en que Irán cambie su sistema político.
Otra cosa es si es posible o no.
Y os preguntaréis ¿De verdad Irán es una
dictadura tan horrible? A fin de cuentas,
tienen elecciones y distintos partidos políticos
¿Verdad? Pues sí y no. Sí, es verdad que
los iraníes pueden votar al presidente. Pero
quien realmente tiene el mando en este país
es el líder supremo: el Ayatola Jamenei.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Jamenei es quien
elije a la mayor parte de los ministros, tiene
la última palabra en política internacional
y en muchas otras leyes importantes.
Por supuesto, las persecuciones a disidentes
políticos son más que frecuentes. Es más,
aunque existe un movimiento importante de
oposición al régimen, apenas hay líderes
concretos ¿Por qué? Porque todos están
muertos, en la cárcel o en el exilio.
Y algo parecido pasa con los partidos políticos.
Veréis, la política en Irán es muy complicada
en parte porque no existen grandes partidos.
Y, por eso, hablamos de facciones. Vamos a
hacer un resumen rápido para que nos entendamos.
Por un lado está la llamada FACCIÓN DURA.
Son los que apoyan el sistema creado por Jomeini
hasta la última coma: es decir, ley religiosa
y con control ferreo del Estado sobre la economía.
Por el otro tenemos a la FACCIÓN REFORMISTA,
que son los que quieren cambiar el régimen
desde dentro.
Como os podéis imaginar, a día de hoy, la
facción reformista tiene muy poca influencia.
Y entre medias tenemos a la llamada FACCIÓN
PRAGMÁTICA, que es a la que pertenece el
actual presidente, Hassan Rouhanni.
Los pragmáticos están a favor de mejorar
sus relaciones con Estados Unidos y liberalizar
la economía pero… mantienen cierto peso
de la religión.
Y ahora viene la segunda pregunta ¿De verdad
es posible que todo este sistema se venga
abajo? Pues lo cierto es que existe esa posibilidad.
Veréis, cuando la economía va bien, es fácil
mantener un sistema autoritario. Muchos ciudadanos
están dispuestos a cambiar libertad por bienestar.
Pero en Irán hace mucho tiempo que desapareció
el bienestar. La divisa iraní se devalúa
día tras día. Y eso lleva a una inflación
brutal. Algunas estimaciones no oficiales
hablan de más de un 100% de inflación para
este año 2018. Y eso significa que los precios
cambian casi de un día para otro. Muchos
alimentos como el pollo están empezando a
escasear. Cada vez hay más miseria en las
ciudades. Y, ni siquiera las privatizaciones
que ha hecho el Gobierno van a salvar la economía.
Lo hemos contado ya aquí, en VisualPolitik,
2018 empezó con protestas multitudinarias
contra el Gobierno de Rouhani. Y muchos de
esos manifestantes eran jóvenes universitarios
que quieren un cambio. Un cambio hacia un
sistema democrático, laico y secular.
Pero la pregunta, la auténtica pregunta es…
¿Es esto suficiente para un cambio de régimen?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a ver un poco de historia.
LA GUARDIA PRETORIANA
En el año 1979 comienza la Revolución Islámica
de Irán. El líder supremo por aquel entonces,
el Ayatola Jomeini, sabía que el ejército
iraní le podía traicionar en cualquier momento.
Tras décadas sirviendo al Shah de Persia,
es difícil cambiar de lealtades de un día
para otro. Así que, para evitar un golpe
de Estado, Jomeini creó a su propio ejército
paralelo, Así es como nació la Guardia Islámica
Revolucionaria, una especie de guardia pretoriana
creada para “preservar el sistema islámico”.
Al principio no era más que un cuerpo formado
por voluntarios. Pero las cosas cambiaron
en los años 80.
En aquellos años, Irán entró en guerra
con Iraq ¿Y a quién enviaron para luchar
en el frente? Exacto, a estos pretorianos
que estaban dispuestos a todo por defender
sus valores. En tiempos de guerra, las arcas
siempre están llenas para comprar más armas.
Así que, día tras día, la Guardia Islámica
Revolucionaria ganaba más influencia, más
armamento y, sobretodo, más experiencia.
Para el final de la guerra Iran-Iraq, esta
Guardia Pretoriana contaba con más de 130.000
soldados más otros tantos cuerpos paralelos
que dependen de ellos.
A día de hoy, tienen hasta sus propios servicios
de inteligencia paralelos. Y pueden hacer
detenciones o seguimientos sin siquiera consultarlo
con el gobierno. En otras palabras, la guardia
islámica revolucionaria es el pilar del régimen
pero… a la vez, es un régimen paralelo.
¿Y por qué son tan importantes?
Veréis, por muy mal que vaya la economía,
es difícil formar un movimiento de oposición
cuando tienes a un cuerpo de élite espiando
a cualquiera posible activista político.
Y sí, hablamos de un cuerpo de élite: perfectamente
entrenados para la guerra híbrida moderna.
Es más, esta Guardia Islámica Revolucionaria
también ha combatido fuera del propio Irán.
Les hemos visto en Siria, Iraq o incluso Afganistán.
Y en todos los casos, los expertos aseguran
que tienen un entrenamiento de primera.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cómo pueden comprar
armas? Es decir, si Irán está tan aislado
del mercado internacional… ¿Cómo pueden
armar a este ejército paralelo? Pues veréis,
lo cierto es que, desde hace décadas, Irán
tiene su propia industria armamentística.
Tal cual como lo oís. Por supuesto, las patentes
son chinas y rusas. Pero los fusiles de asalto,
las balas y hasta muchos vehículos de combate
se fabrican en el propio Irán.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando! ¿No
les van a afectar las sanciones económicas?
A fin de cuentas, si Irán no tiene dinero,
tampoco lo tendrá su ejército ¿verdad?
Pues… mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
nada más lejos de la realidad.
La presión externa y la falta de competidores
extranjeros ayudará a la Guardia Revolucionaria
a consolidar su control sobre la conomía
de Irán.
Ali Alfoneh, Instituto de los Estados del
Golfo en Washington
Para que hagáis una idea, un tercio de la
economía de Irán está en manos de la Guardia
Revolucionaria. Son los dueños de muchos
monopolios estatales. Y eso incluye a empresas
petroleras, refinerías o constructoras. Por
ejemplo, el 51% de Irán Telecom es suyo.
Si a eso le sumamos que están exentos de
pagar casi cualquier impuesto, tenemos que
la Guardia Revolucionaria tiene una economía
totalmente sostenible. Y con un ejército
paralelo, tan bien entrenado y tan bien armado,
es muy difícil conseguir un cambio de régimen.
Pero si pensábais que esta es la única baza
de Irán, estábais muy, pero que muy equivocados.
Ahora mismo lo vais a ver.
¡CHINA ACUDE AL RESCATE!
Lo hemos dicho ya varias veces en otros vídeos
de esta serie: China va a seguir comprando
petróleo a Irán. Lo cierto es que no pueden
dejar de hacerlo. China necesita torrentes
de zumo de dinosaurio. Y, durante décadas,
Irán es su 6º proveedor más importante.
Hablamos de más de 800.000 barriles de petróleo
que llegan de Irán todos los días. Con esas
cifras, es muy difícil cambiar de proveedores
de un día para otro.
¡Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando! Si
habéis visto los vídeos anteriores, ya sabéis
que Estados Unidos tiene un arma secreta para
evitar que nadie compre petróleo a Irán
¿Verdad? Hablamos de las aseguradores. Básicamente,
ningún barco petrolero puede atracar en un
puerto si no está asegurado. Y casi todas
las empresas de seguros que trabajan en el
mundo del petróleo son Europeas o Estadounidenses.
Así es que ¿Cómo puede China seguir comprando
petróleo a Irán? Pues… atentos.
Exclusiva: China se pasa a los barcos iraníes
para mantener el flujo de petróleo a pesar
de las sanciones de Estados Unidos
Tal cual como lo oís: a falta de aseguradoras,
Irán se va a hacer cargo del transporte y
de todos los riesgos ¿Qué un barco petrolero
se hunde? Irán paga ¿Qué no puede llegar
a su destino? Irán paga ¿Qué hay que cuidar
el mantenimiento de los barcos petroleros?
Irán paga…
¡Pero aquí no queda la cosa! Pensadlo bien,
si el resto del mundo va a dejar de invertir
en Irán… ¿Qué es lo que tenemos? ¡Exacto!
Vía libre para la inversión china. Y eso
explica noticias como esta.
Una empresa China invertirá 2000 millones
de dólares en una refinería de petróleo
en Irán
¡Lo habéis oído bien! China está aprovechando
el vacío para comprar todo lo que puede en
Irán. Es más, las empresas chinas también
están aprovechando las inversiones que han
hecho otras empresas. Por ejemplo, TOTAL es
la petrolera francesa. En 2016, comenzaron
la construcción del que sería la mayor planta
de extracción de gas natural del mundo. Ahora,
con las sanciones de Trump, es muy posible
que tengan que abandonar ese proyecto ¿Y
quién está dispuesto a comprarlo? ¡Exacto!
¡China!
Para que os hagáis una idea, en verano de
2018, el Banco para el Desarrollo Chino ha
anunciado que dará más de 15.000 millones
de dólares en préstamos para proyectos en
Irán. Y diréis ¿Eso es mucho o poco dinero?
Pues… para que os hagáis una idea, ya ha
servido para empezar a construir 5 hospitales
nuevos.
¿Y qué me decís de las empresas? ¿Recordáis
que os decía que Irán es uno de los mayores
productores de coches de la región? Pues
una de las principales marcas del país, SAIPA,
ya ha firmado una Joint venture con otra empresa
china que se llama BRILLIANCE.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque esto es sólo
el principio! A ver ¿Cuál es el proyecto
más ambicioso que está llevando a cabo el
Gobierno Chino? ¡Exacto! La llamada “nueva
ruta de la seda”. Ese proyecto “one Belt
one road” esa gran apuesta de Xi Jimping.
Pues… adivinad cual podría ser uno de sus
principales nodos.
China pone los ojos en Irán como un importante
centro para la iniciativa Belt and Road
Por el momento, ya están renovando varias
vías de trenes. La idea es conectar las principales
ciudades de Irán con trenes de alta velocidad
para el transporte de productos. Y diréis
¿Por qué Irán? ¿Qué tiene de importante
este país? Pues… mirad este mapa y lo entenderéis.
Imaginad un cargamento de teléfonos móviles
que viaja desde China, pasa por Asia Central…
y luego sigue por Irán hasta llegar a Turquía.
Se trata de una ruta perfecta para que China
pueda enviar sus productos a Europa. Por supuesto
que todo esto no son más que proyectos. Y
las empresas chinas ya están teniendo más
de un problema con sus inversiones en Asia
Central. Pero eso lo contaremos en otros vídeos.
Lo cierto es que China está empezando a invertir
seriamente en Irán ¿Significa esto que Xi
Jimping va a salvar la economía de Irán?
¡Por supuesto que no! ¿Pero será suficiente
como para que pueda sobrevivir el régimen
de los Ayatolás? Pues… probablemente sí.
Y eso explica que, en los últimos años,
las relaciones políticas entre estos dos
países sean cada vez más fluídas.
Xi Jinping mantiene conversaciones con el
Presidente de Irán, Hassan Rouhani
Y ahora la pregunta es para vosotros ¿De
verdad creéis que las sanciones de Trump
servirán para acabar con el régimen de los
Ayatolás? ¿O más bien lo contrario? Podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y si queréis entender más a fondo todos
los detalles sobre las sanciones nucleares
a Irán, podéis ver los últimos vídeos
que hemos publicado sobre este tema.
Como siempre, no olvidéis suscribíos a VisualPolitik
y darle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE,
compartidlo con vuestros amigos y nos vemos
en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto!